so the destiny one point Oh 2.2 hotfix
patch came out today big nerves to the
assault rifles as well as severe nurse
to the middle class the VEX middle class
which was arguably the best weapon in
the game it used to pump out ridiculous
damage not only in PvE but in PvP I
think enough people whined about dying
to it in PvP that they finally nerfed it
by 34% it's to the point where it's the
same as my assault rifle my servos
regime that smacks of 300 where's my vex
middle class is only a 283 they do
almost the same damage whereas in the
past you know my the vex middle class
used to beast used to do 385 crid stay
the head now doing like 147 so they've
severely nerfed the the middle class and
in terms of the assault rifle they've
nerfed the damage as well as the
stability at range so obviously that's
another big nerf my sir oh so used to do
you know 300 to 500 crit to the head on
the bottom half of the clip right now
the last bullet is only doing 293 from
earlier tests which is also a big nerf
but they have bluff Scout rifles I think
sky rifles are going to be the best gun
in the game currently and that my scout
rifle buff was doing about 345 crits to
the head consistently which is double
what in assault rifle is doing right now
I think they nerf the assault rifles
because too many people are using it and
not enough people are using like the
Scout rifles or the pulse rifles they
haven't actually bluffed the pulse
rifles but expect a buff there
eventually with in terms of the hotfix
and the other big notable nerf is that
they have finally fixed the exploit for
the Templar fight in the raid you can't
be on the platforms anymore used to be
able to choose the Templar boss and the
Oracles from different platforms and
where they couldn't hit you but you can
hit them they're fixing that so it's
going to be you know more difficult to
get through
hard mode now expect that expect people
to have more difficulty with that but
yeah some other subtle nerfs the shotgun
range is not as far anymore so expect to
get less owned hopefully in pvp by that
by that garbage and they added accuracy
to hand cannons in the air which is an
interesting buff but maybe that's pretty
good for hand can users expect more
nursed and fixes to the raid they
haven't actually fixed the a Theon
cheese where you can push a thing on off
the ledge but I think Bungie devs have
already tweeted out that they're those
hot fixes will be coming those things
will be looked at as well as general
buffs to exotics that are currently
under performing and maybe a look at
other exotics are kind of over
performing so expect more class balance
and weapon balance going forward as well
as like raid balance but that's kind of
the patch rip rip mythic lasts I'm sorry
I just got mine I'm sad assault rifle
I'm sad I'm gonna Bank those things
scout rifle all the way patch 1.02 point
to